eduardo how are you
i'm doing great what about you better
than i deserve sir how can we help
i knew you were going to say that it's
so iconic
so
anyways um i don't know what to do i'm
kind of stuck in the pickle right now um
debating on whether i should continue uh
school
or if
i should take the upcoming semester off
just to
dedicate my time to paying off my debt
um so i'm currently going to school and
i'm double majoring in business
administration and transformational
ministry
and
i have about
currently i've racked up about eleven
thousand dollars in student loan debt
and that's not even from the tuition
it's just from
um dorming and housing stuff like that
usually fafsa just covers all my tuition
and
i have
i have a 200 car payment right now
um that doesn't even include insurance
on the insurance i'm paying 200
and it's just getting overwhelming
because i'm only making like
700 700 at most each two weeks
and all my money is basically going to
my car so i don't know if i should
you know continue going to school and
keep paying this off or
just pick up the next semester and
dedicate that to just paying off my debt
and on top of that i have three thousand
dollars
um
three thousand three thousand seven
hundred dollars in credit card debts
okay
and how old are you
i am going to be 21 on saturday when
will you graduate
i am expecting to graduate in the spring
of 2024
okay three more years then or two two
and a half more years okay
two years from this spring
okay
so um sounds to me like you have an
income problem
you don't make any money
yeah i'm i'm an assistant manager uh and
you break a fix at the moment um you
don't make any money you can make you
can make more than that in three nights
delivering pizzas
i mean i don't care if you're the sister
i don't care if you're the manager
they're title and worthy and you're not
paying you anything
seven hundred dollars every two weeks
you're starving to death
so you you need to yeah you need to get
some more jobs
yeah you know the thing is that um i was
working full time before i went back to
school um
this year i was working 40 hours a week
up until uh
up until september which is when i went
back to school so now i'm only working
about
want to say like 25 hours a week yeah
you're going to get back to 40 and
probably at a different job
you're going to make more money
yeah yeah because
because the issue is
if that income
doesn't go up what's going to happen is
everything that i'm seeing from
credit cards to taking out some student
loans just for your housing like you
said
not even for tuition the car all of that
just continues to be magnified if you
just continued on this road and so
it's either pausing school right now
going full time cleaning some of this up
and then
going back to school or
getting your income up so high that
you're able to at least cash flow
your expenses on your basic budget
through college which is it's difficult
to just live and eat and pay your car
payment with what you make yeah forget
it forget college and so you're just not
making enough money dude you have an
income problem
and so yeah you're either going to quit
school and and fix the income problem or
you're going to fix incomes problems
stay in school i just fix it and stay in
school
i just like take i mean uber eats and
deliver pizzas and be an assistant
manager and work all the time you don't
need to even turn on your television
ever again until you graduate and to
find things on campus like being an ra
or something that your housing even is
covered like finding different choices
that you can make in the next two years
even with that is helpful because i mean
you've racked up 11 000 and said it
wasn't even the tuition so yeah you need
to look at your living expenses as well
yeah that's kind of i mean eleven
thousand dollars in debt already
i don't know i guess you're in la
southern california so it's like so yeah
it's expensive down there i was like
that's a pretty nice
well we're paying a car payment out of
it and we're paying car insurance the
sql of the car payment yeah that's in
there too and 3700 in credit card debt
so
uh what's happening is is that you are
you know you're running around
uh trying to touch all these different
bases and you know the money to touch
all the bases
you know you gotta pay uh uh books and
you gotta pay dorm and you gotta pay car
you gotta pay car insurance and also the
credit card comes out and you take a
little break you go out to eat and you
couldn't afford to
and because you're stressed out and
dude you just need to i'm telling you i
worked 40 to 60 hours a week and got out
in four years
so i'm not asking you to do something
that's something you're a boomer
yeah like we we worked at our age
i'm kidding you made that joke earlier
today that you're a boomer i was like
well that's what people are probably
thinking pretty well the current the
current version of hitting on dave
ramsey okay so here's my question no but
for real though what's what is that is
it a mindset shift that you've seen from
like
no it's just nobody ever telling us what
the problem was i think he's not afraid
of work no not him but you but like what
you're seeing though because i feel like
his situation is so normal today
when i was doing it weren't doing it i
guess that's fair i'm just thinking the
whole idea of working 40 to 60 hours a
week and going to school
that's like not even that people don't
think that's an option like that you
know what i'm saying but you
you know there's people in every
generation that have done it but they're
not they're not the bigger part and yes
we have
rogue people in every generation so i
mean it's not it's not like work is
something that's new to millennials or
z's no
millennials and these aren't afraid of
hard work we got a bunch of them working
here and they look like animals they're
awesome yeah uh so it's you know it's
not workaholism it's saying i've gotta
i've got a busted i'm in the middle of a
dadgum thing here oh a thousand percent
i gotta get with it and so yeah um
you know but it was um
uh uh it just didn't uh
it it probably just depends a little bit
on how you're brought up it depends a
little bit on what's going on i mean
we've got christina here on the
personalities team sitting in here right
now as a matter of fact in the other
room and um you know she got 500 000
worth of scholarships the best-selling
book off of that and worked her tail end
off yeah yeah but her mom's a single mom
and her mom said you know this is how
you're going to get through school
that's what you're going to do and
you know uh
you know anthony wrote about it in the
book that free degree
work is a big part of it and college
choice is a big part of it and
scholarships are a big part of it those
are the three things you do to go
through school free but i mean the other
thing is you can't
we have never told people and you and i
started telling people this
before anthony and before christina that
you can go through school debt-free but
we never told people it's on minimum
wage
right right you can't do it remember
yeah so you got to do something
different i mean you got to walk dogs
you got to cut grass you got to have a
side hustle of some kind but you can
make you can make money oh yeah and even
today
nannying's 25 bucks an hour right you
know absolutely and so
you can work you can find something to
do that pays good yeah especially right
now i was about to say now it's crazy
how many people are paying yeah freaking
target will pay you 15 20 bucks an hour
to work over there and you don't even
have to be the assistant manager yeah so
dude that's your answer seriously this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is our
co-host today number one best-selling
author lately of the book know yourself
know your money which is one of our 10
items on sale so be sure and check that
out at ramseysolutions.com lots of
goodies on sale there and uh the new
book baby steps millionaires that comes
out january the 11th
is on pre-sale right now this first book
i've done in eight years matter of fact
the last full trade book i did was with
you we did smart money smart kids
last time i did a full trade it's like a
whole other lifetime ago yeah
sure was and uh and that was one of the
first ones that we uh when we opened up
ramsey press and uh because the one
before that was andre leadership of
simon schuster so good stuff so
obviously this is ramsey press as well
and i just came out of a meeting with a
target and uh
with updates on the sales in target and
barnes and noble amazon uh airport all
placing large orders for baby step
millionaires good good to be back in the
game after eight years and see what
happens so if you want to be a
millionaire i can show you exactly how
tens of thousands of people are now
millionaires because they followed
the stuff we teach it's not because of
me i didn't give them any money i'm not
magic i'm just a little hillbilly guy
that showed you how to live common sense
but when you live common sense in any
area of your life it changes everything
and that includes walking through these
proven baby steps that people have done
over and over and over again and it
turns them into millionaires so i can
show you how to do it regardless of who
you are regardless of where you come
from regardless of your background and
i'll prove it to you six different ways
in this book
so when you order for 20 you get 100
worth of bonus items including the baby
steps millionaire's audio book the baby
steps millionaire's e-book the legacy
journey audio book and e-book the baby
steps millionaires live stream which is
going to be done here in our lobby and
the lobby seats are already sold out and
it'll be done in january and you'll be
able to watch it live stream if you're
pre-purchased the book uh ramsey smart
tax you can file your taxes free anna
ramsay plus 30-day free trial all of
that at ramseysolutions.com
so be sure you check it out
and uh we'll try to help you out any way
we can with any of that and rachel your
new wallet is there as well for
christmas right yes it is the wallet is
not new but the color this is a new
color yes what color would you say this
is
um brown brown
it's probably some fancy schmancy brown
but i know it's because it's a fancy
shmancy wallet
i like to say it makes budgeting
beautiful you know it's just oh wow
that's a good tag line no it is but the
but the wallet uh envelope system it
it's all built in together
dress up wallet yes and it's um made
with authentic leather it's really
really nice great quality and there are
three colors but the newest one brown is
there so you can check it out
ramseysolutions.com
the folks that make it
it's just an incredible company oh i
know join we partnered with them they're
out of um a company out of india and so
they help
employ people out of really just hard
situations and give them trade and skill
and so i know that's kind of basically
one of the things i love about it too is
basically they're not on the street
because they make stuff like this yes
and then every wallet you'll have a card
with the person that made it
so it's just it's awesome so you you
buy something that's going to help you
with your money and you truly do help
people
uh across the world that you may never
meet but it's it's awesome yeah and it
just
smells so good gotta love leather i love
just going in a leather shop when you
open the rachel cruise box i buy stuff
that i don't even need just because of
that leather stuff it's just leather
leather stuff it's leather stuff so good
i know but it's there very cool all
right all at ramseysolutions.com amy is
in dallas texas hi amy how are you
i'm great mr ramsay it's good to talk to
you again the the last time i got to was
during the millionaire segment so oh wow
gotta get a chance to talk to you again
cool so you're you're an everyday
millionaire or a baby steps millionaire
yes sir i actually have a question i get
to ask a question then but i still uh
trying to trying to continue to learn
and even though i'm a millionaire but i
still have a question for you
okay
all right um so i've paid about i mean
listening to you has really got me to be
more gazelle intense on just that last
step to paying off the house step
i paid about 70 000 of it this year
and i'm kind of wondering what's next
once i'm in baby steps i've also front
loaded my children's
529s
i'll do a little bit more next year but
it's not going to break the bank or
anything so
uh kind of a kind of a what's next class
i know i made a big mistake
in my when i started my career i
started contributing to my traditional
401k as opposed to my roth
it's not a big one
for it i mean you're just a little less
rich than you would have been okay yeah
so i'm just kind of wondering you know
like you know okay what do i do now and
i'm maxing out by roth 401k
roth ira both myself and my husband and
the house is paid off now
yes sir okay good for you and you're a
millionaire
yes sir how old are you
32 and my husband's 31. good night amy
that's amazing you're amazing what do
you guys do for a living
uh i said this in the millionaires i met
surprise surprise or engineers
yes both of both of your engineers i
remember talking to you now okay
pretty cool because a 32 year old
millionaire following the baby steps is
pretty cool that's what i was just
talking about talking about that book
coming out so you're you're amazing so
here's the thing um i'm going to send
you have you got a copy of the legacy
journey yet
i have not let me send you a copy of
that okay
because that's really a baby step seven
thing so here here's the thing
number one the first thing you do is
exactly what you've done you max out all
retirements
keep the government's hands off of
anything you can't
okay now and then you can use what
you're doing there as a part of this
second suggestion
sharon and i and anytime we're meeting
with high income high net worth
individuals we teach them the same exact
thing and oddly enough it's the same
things we taught in smart money smart
kids there's only three things you can
do with money
right rachel
let me answer it yeah
pop quiz amy here we go gift savings and
yeah
yeah
you need to have you need to take this
and percentage of your income
for the coming year before the year
starts
and say i'm going to spend this
percentage of my income on enjoyment
lifestyle
and you need to enjoy money you've
worked really really hard difficult for
me i know but if you don't do it within
here's a weird thing it's not as
difficult once you've allocated it if
you said this money is to be bought is
to buy something stupid then when you
buy something stupid if it's like oh
that's what i was supposed to do with it
okay because you labeled it that right
you're just gonna go buy you a whatever
a toy i don't care or you go on the trip
or you do whatever
and because you can afford it shut up
okay then the second thing you do is you
say here's the percentage of my income
that's going to generosity
and here's the percentage of my income
that's going to investments
and those three percentages added
together need to equal 100.
yes and that's pretty easy and and so
and the weird thing is that it'll keep
you from feeling out of control with
your spending even though you spend a
good deal of money on something
compared to any to other time in your
life but it's a small percentage of your
world
like i got a guy i was meeting with
making 10 million a year and he spends
five percent of his income on lifestyle
well that's freaking 500 000 dollars
that's a pretty i mean it's only five
percent you know
so and the rest of it is generosity and
investing
and so you know when you do it when you
look at it that way it's like you got to
be kidding me but he can go buy whatever
car he wants to buy travel wherever he
wants to travel virtually live and buy
another house every couple of years if
he wants to another another vacation
home somewhere out of that and so you
just have to allocate a percentage to
fun yes slash lifestyle amy i'll say
this
my husband and i we've learned
in our process of all of this and now we
are on baby step seven is that we always
need a goal though and i'm the spender
so like me even you're like i have an
issue spending i'm like yeah that's
never my problem i'm great with it i i
can enjoy but mine but winston and i we
we sit down together because i'm like i
don't want to flippantly
because you're on baby step 7 it can
kind of feel like you can kind of just
coast and go so you still want a goal so
whether it's maybe you want to build a
home one day and do it with all cash and
keep your current one as a rental maybe
you guys want to invest in some real
estate a commercial real estate building
there in dallas i don't know what it is
but having something that you work
towards within a five-year period is
really helpful at least for my husband
because we're close to your age yeah um
and winston hadn't bought a truck in 12
years this time he buys a truck he needs
to get her well tell toyota that their
tundras
tell winston
it backwards i mean you need to the
point is you need to enjoy it you need
to enjoy it and that's that that's part
of the equation it's not the only part
but allocate by percentages give your
money names
and then you can do it guilt-free and
responsibly yes
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they're here they're in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt-free stage
they did it
christopher and deborah are with us
welcome guys how are you great thank you
where do you guys live up in wilmington
delaware all right and all the way to
tennessee to do a debt free scream what
a weird activity yes
how much debt have you guys paid off so
paid off 260 thousand dollars was a
hundred thousand hundred thousand ninety
thousand dollars we cash flowed
another um seventy thousand dollars for
a total of 260. wow good for you that's
incredible how long did this take took
us 39 months good for you and your range
of income during that time 149 000 to
258 000. wow what do you guys do for a
living
so i work in law enforcement as a police
officer
and i manage a self storage facility ah
very cool good for you guys okay so you
sold something that was 70.
that was the 70. you cashflow 190 and
then there were some what's the other
70. you had that in the bank and you
just threw it at it or what no so we we
cashflowed our sons our youngest sons
college and then we had to replace the
hvac and then we also cashflowed our uh
25th hour now your 25th one renewal for
anniversary vowel renewal okay that's
not 190 000. you said you cash flowed
190 000.
39 months it took what kind of debt was
the 190 our house you paid off your
house
oh congratulations to you guys these are
weirdos yes you are awesome so proud of
you how old are you two i'm 48 and she's
a little younger there you go i like it
a good answer
well played
well played incredibly well done this is
awesome awesome awesome i love it i'm so
proud of you guys thank you so uh here's
the thing
oh man absolutely amazing so uh uh what
got you got you guys started on this 39
months ago so back in august of 2017 i
went down to virginia for a police
officer's funeral
and as i sat there in the church reading
the funeral card at the bottom of the
funeral card it said instead of flowers
please give money to the family
emergency fund to defend you know please
consider donating money to the family
instead of flowers
and i sat there in back of the church i
looked up and i see the wife and the
sons at the front of the church
and it just instantly became terrified
and i said oh my god i can't do this to
my family i can't leave them like this
and you know as i told my wife i called
my wife on the drive home and i said you
know for all i know maybe this guy just
never liked flowers i said but i'm
sitting there in the church
reading this and i look up and i see a
wife and her sons up there i just became
terrified saying oh my goodness i said
you know they weren't prepared
and i said i can't do this and that just
that started us down the rabbit hole and
i never came back out for it wow deborah
had you been thinking about anything
financial wise up until that point did
you feel
kind of financially insecure if you will
did you want to always always i was
always robbing peter to pay paul and i
was sick of living paycheck to paycheck
so when he called me and he was very
intense about it he was very focused and
i knew it was going to be game on from
there but i was either going to fall in
line or else i was gonna fall behind
and so we we revamped everything from
that point we went now we redid our life
insurance we did our wills we have a
legacy book put together now for
everything
and we wanted to get rid of everything
because how did you get plugged into us
so i i've always known about it i've
always been kind of a you know a
spreadsheet kind of person and want to
look at my numbers and we just never
followed the program he's been a nerd
since the beginning and then i think it
just kind of kicked in
we read the total money makeover a
couple years ago we were davish we
weren't really following the plan and
then i think we just kicked it in and
was just like you know we've had it yeah
this is what we're going to do
it's very you know his job is very
volatile at any point in time he could
go and leave us so we needed to have
everything
all our ducks in a row so was what was
left was just the mortgage was that 190
so you guys didn't have a ton of
consumer debt obviously so when we
started i went to the funeral in 2017
and then that that started that day we
were done that day
and then by january 2018 we paid off all
our consumer debt yeah we got rid of all
that we didn't have a lot of it was a
couple car loans and one credit card
we've never been real huge spenders but
we've done a lot of stupid stuff yeah
with it so once we get that done and
then he was just like you know it's time
to do the house
yeah now here you are yeah so we did fbo
at home and then we went uh you know
once we were even babysit four we went
to fpu again at the church uh with a
group with everyone else also it's
awesome just to stay focused yes good
for y'all well done i'm so proud of you
so what's this house worth uh about 275
yeah very cool how much is in your
retirement so we're we're about halfway
there to be millionaires all right we're
a little over halfway there now good for
you well done thank you yeah so three or
four more years you're going to be there
yes that's awesome well done i'm so
proud of you guys so what is this go
ahead sorry we were talking to someone
in the last segment about
about working together with your spouse
on different goals so paying off your
house is a huge goal together so what
did that do
for your marriage how do you feel like
did that unify you guys
strengthen our marriage totally i don't
think we were on the same page um when
it started out he would have always had
all the funds he dealt with everything
he paid everything and then he was
deployed
and then i had to take over everything
and then when he came back i still had
everything
and we still weren't on the same page
and it wasn't until we sat down got
together did our budget meetings wrote
our budget out that it it strengthened
our marriage it did wonders it's awesome
we've gone from one opposite end of the
spectrum to another from the point where
our electrical use comes different
colored envelopes and that's that's how
we knew how far behind we were on
electric bill yeah you know to our very
first house i lost a foreclosure car
repossessed two years later here we are
now completely focused completely
different and now everything's done and
uh we'll be able to go into retirement
with absolutely no doubts at all all the
time well you're doing it okay so that's
what's going to ask though if there's a
couple listening right now and they're
you know 25 years old and they were
where you guys were with just kind of
like some credit cards car loans i don't
know like just
ugh that feeling
what do you what do you wish you had
said to the 25 year old version of you
it's amazing and you never realize until
you have that paycheck and today is my
payday and my paycheck today stays with
me it doesn't have to go out the door
there's no one else you know trying to
get trying to get money from us anymore
our paychecks you know our paycheck now
pays for tomorrow instead of paying for
yesterday and that's our biggest thing
for us there's a tweetable line i think
staying focused also um knowing what
we're both doing having that budget
knowing you know this is what's coming
in this is where it needs to go
sitting down and just talking and just
we have dream we have dreamwalks where
we'll just go now and we'll walk
and just dream about what do we want to
do in the future what do we want what do
we want our kids to look like what are
we going to do how do we want our legacy
to look yeah let's be ready to go you
guys so proud of you outside the two of
you who are your biggest cheerleaders
our children we have five children so
they are all as much as they make fun of
all of us they've pretty much all fell
in line too yeah
look at that school debt free paying off
things stuff like that so they finish
they make fun of us all the time
especially the nerd here they make fun
of him all the time but they have
totally supported us and been behind us
sounds like they make fun of you but
there's a lot of respect yeah well it's
nice knowing that you know now all the
kids have gone to school college and
they've gone debt-free they've all got
their roth accounts set up they you know
they're not worried about a credit score
they've got money in the bank now which
that's a family chain that's a family
tree change yes yes yeah way to go
congratulations thank you well we've got
an advanced copy for you for baby steps
millionaires because you're that's your
next chapter we were already discussing
that uh the book actually comes out
january 11th but i know a guy so we're
gonna get you a copy today
and uh get you one of the advanced
copies that we send out to the press is
what we'll do and uh good stuff man and
also a copy of the total money makeover
which you've read but you can give it
away now you can pass forward uh find
somebody that's uh that 25 year old 35
year old version of you guys and before
they know it they'll be you and uh 260
000
in debt and cash flow lighter
well done very very very well done all
right it's christopher and deborah from
newark delaware oh man absolutely
powerful 260 thousand dollars paid off
in 39 months making 149 to 258 count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream ready
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i love it
well done you guys
that's how it's done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author lately of the
book know yourself know your money which
is now on sale for ten dollars as part
of our big huge christmas sale
so apparently black friday now
identifies self-identifies as a week so
black friday is now a week long and um
you can get that any so we've had a
black friday special running the entire
week yeah and so uh yeah you can get all
other stuff at serious bargains at
ramseysolutions.com
so be sure you check that out
all right up next is going to be brian
in gulfport mississippi hey brian
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hey rachel how you doing today
great man what's up
hey so i have a question about turnover
rates for you on mutual funds so i know
it can be advantageous to have a lower
turnover rate if you're doing it outside
of like a roth vehicle correct um inside
of the roth vehicle does the turnover
rate really matter all that much
with it being a little bit more tax you
know it's completely tax-free so it's
irrelevant
right okay that's what i thought so
that's why
that's why for instance uh like a uh a
growth in income or an s p 500 might
have a turnover rate of five percent
meaning they only sell five percent of
their stocks in a given year and so only
five percent of the gains on the that
fund would be taxable in that year uh
versus say an aggressive growth stock
mutual fund might have a 200 percent
turnover rate meaning they might roll
the whole thing over twice which means
every 100 of those gains would be
taxable in a year uh whether you cashed
it out or not now when it's in a roth
ira none of it's taxable so it doesn't
matter
and that's why we're using that's why we
use an aggressive growth stock mutual
fund inside of a roth but i don't hold
aggressive growth stock mutual funds
outside of tax protected stuff
right on right now because um yeah we
have a few different selections within a
401k and you know of course the index is
low and then we have a couple that are
like 80 and 90 yeah and their 10-year
benchmarks you know are
quite i say quite a bit higher anywhere
from five six seven percent higher than
the index so but they're also more and
they're also more volatile if you look
at them they're they're wild or they're
a wilder ride that's why you don't put
it all in the wild ride and you don't
put it all in the grandmother driving
her 84 chevrolet down the road either
okay so you put it in put you know you
have the safe ride and the wild route
and you mix them together to get a good
portfolio balance
right right right on
cool man thanks for calling in open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five
two
rachel there is a
new awareness
of investing details
in the last 24 months that i don't know
if i've seen in 30 years of doing this
really i always wondered that about
trends that you've seen because of that
i mean that's a young guy right there
who actually really knows his stuff yeah
i mean he's asking like detailed nerdy
mutual fun nerd questions right right
and he really knows his stuff and and
you know that's the good side of this
investment awareness stuff um and you
and i were taping a show this morning
and we're talking about the bad side is
that there's a right now there's a fresh
batch
of people falling for get rich quick
like i haven't seen in a long time yep
there's a lot of get-rich-quick stuff
going on nothing down real estate
bitcoin gold people are chasing they're
chasing quick returns quick quick money
quick easy money quick easy money and
they're gonna get burned they always do
when you put your whole life when you
bet your whole life on a wild ride uh uh
but it that has come in waves i mean i
when i was 22
in 1982 i went to a nothing down real
estate seminar yeah and that got me
started doing nothing down real estate
which i later went broke because of so i
was part of that gay rich quick movement
the movement that followed that was the
infomercial movement yes the cable tv
went bananas after that late 80s right
and so everybody and his brother dave
del dotto and all these guys had
midnight tv every time you turned on
midnight tv there was any channel there
was a get rich quick real estate thing
on and uh it may have been one more
since then but uh from the late 80s to
now this one they'll get rich in real
estate right now people are that because
real estate real estate oh inflation
inflation
and they're just you know they just lost
their mind out so how much of the
because there has to be an element of
what we've all been through
you know from 2020 and 2021
of the pandemic and all that right that
there's like this
i think it's psychological i agree like
there's something that has shifted
whether it's hey i want to control more
that i know more you know there's a
level of like the detail like you're
saying people are wanting to understand
their money a little bit more because
the fear of realizing oh my gosh what if
everything's good like you know i feel
like there's that
and then there's the well you live once
like oh god who knows
yeah who knows what's going to happen
like let's let's see the farm on bitcoin
but the traditional investing plan yeah
feels better i mean i've even talked to
some of my friends about it and they'll
like question me and they're like so you
reap you guys really you really only do
like your retire you just do 401k roth
ira i was like yeah we have a mutual
fund and what's tonight we do we'll do
paid for real estate on the side we just
have one rental right now but but i'm
like and that's kind of our next goal
but but that's it and and it feels
it feels boring and it doesn't feel um
like you could be like you could be
doing so much more there's an urgency
to well this whole idea that all of a
sudden you had the entire population
realize we're all gonna die
you know and they hadn't thought about
it a bunch of them didn't think about it
and they all went crap i'm gonna die
and covet did that it scared the crud
out of people right yep and you go i
mean we all had at least a moment of
that somewhere in there like this thing
could wipe us all out sure nothing left
but the lizards and the dogs i don't
know but you know what i mean it's just
but uh but but there's a little bit of
that but then but then other people
stayed in that psychosis longer sure but
it made us aware of our mortality and
what it did was some people's it
panicked to them yes and that's what's
driving some of this get rich quick yep
the get-rich-quick things i got in were
more greed-based
this one's more panicked i might not be
here long so i've got to get it quick
it's a fear urgency driving it and it's
really dangerous yeah because it's good
because you're not going to die like as
soon as you think you're going to with
that that as soon as that fear that
irrational fear that's driving this says
you're going to die and then you're and
so what's going to happen is you're
going to out you're going to live long
enough to find out how stupid you've
been
that's what you know like i lived long
enough to find out how my greed
stupidity was and it took me down i lost
everything to start again
you live you know the only way to avoid
that's die
you're but otherwise you're going to
live long enough to reap what you have
sown and man you have sown the whirlwind
and you're going to reap the freaking
tornado that's what you get you're going
it's going to come through your house
and you're going to go oh my god i was
so scared and i got in a hurry yeah
because as soon as you get desperate
right after you get desperate you get
stupid
it's in it's in the car
no decisions you do i mean we all do and
there's there's a little desperation
there the bible says we're just here for
a vapor yeah just here for a second yep
and that's true
but it's not to panic you
it's to say i'm going to be diligent i'm
going to be serious-minded
wise but i'm not going to brood over it
i i i might make it two days i might
make it two decades but i'm not gonna
brood over it that's what i've got left
and that's my time
and the time that i have here i'm gonna
be wise with it and i'm gonna be
functioning
thinking long term not thinking yolo
right absolutely and we were saying this
morning even
until something has a long track record
and that's the problem
with a lot of this stuff even you put
crypto in this that
the tracker is just not long enough to
go and bet everything of these people
you know that are cashing out of the
market completely and going into these
these industries that don't have a
proven track record and that's what you
want to gamble and you want to set fire
to a percentage of your net worth
possibly uh because you think
something's kind of cool you want to buy
a single stock in tesla okay you want to
buy because that's oh now you're well i
mean
well but i mean
there's a difference between the car and
the company
okay this is
just and but tesla has a much better
track record today than say it did 36 or
48 months ago sure absolutely it's much
less risk now because it's lived longer
that's right that's right it's it's
stayed alive yes you know and so it
might be the next iphone right now it
might be the next apple i don't know are
you gonna get a tesla no i didn't say
that i said do you have it do you have
an iphone i do i do have an iphone yeah
but i'm just saying but the that it's
not a point of consumer consuming it
right now i'm talking about investing in
the freaking company messing with you i
know so you're talking about investing
all i see is me driving a computer and i
really want to want to drive that tesla
you want to drive a battery i'm sorry
you say tesla and i
hey you don't have to deal with it if it
doesn't make noise it's not a real car
ridge it is but it's faster than your
car if it has to have a it has to have a
loud muffler or a redneck is not allowed
to drive i will race you it's redneck
law redneck constitution says it must
have a loud muffler
you can so your rednecks are not allowed
to drive a battery we're not allowed you
are changing your family tree for the
good
[Laughter]
of electric cars
[Music]
i don't even know what we're saying
failed as a father just invest in mutual
funds
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today her new newest book is a number
one bestseller as well know yourself
know your money it's now on sale at
ramseysolutions.com for ten dollars as
part of our big black friday black
friday week black friday week um sale
for christmas it's a big deal check it
out at ramseysolutions.com the phone
number here triple eight eight two five
five two two five hunter is in
birmingham hey hunter what's up
hey dave hey rachel first of all a huge
honor to be talking with you guys i've
been listening for about a year now um
i'm 19 i'm
about to finish my first semester in
undergraduate and i didn't go to a big
state school like y'all recommend i went
to my or you know i went to my local
community
four-year college
and i want to go to med school and i
want to know how to do it right and stay
out of debt um and i know it's like
thirty thousand dollars a semester for
med school and i'm just working
part-time i'm not sure how i can manage
you know staying out of debt and you
know becoming a doctor
very difficult a very difficult
challenge um
there's a couple of tracks that you can
try
but they're fairly narrow doors that
you'll have to squeeze through
the best one and the most efficient one
is to start studying
fellowships
start studying studying the md phd
programs
and in essence the the core of that is
you go to work for the university where
the medical school is
and you are an employee so you go to med
school free
okay but the the number of
uh slots for those is very low they're
very prized for obvious reasons okay
there's not a lot of them but you you
would you might be uh teaching biology
as a as a professor's assistant
uh while you're going through med school
you know if for undergrads and uh you
may be teaching undergrads and that kind
of stuff you're probably going to have
some time tied up doing stuff like that
that's generally how these fellowships
work but they're called md
phd
programs probably the most famous one is
duke
and you can check into them but uh i'm
not sure if vanderbilt has one
i don't know locally but most most
universities have some form of that and
you can do that the
second thing you can do and this one's
even harder and but i've actually met
people that pulled it off
is i start
soliciting the drug companies
because they all want docs as customers
in the future
and start talking to pfizer and start
talking to whoever's out there that
whatever uh brand of whatever drug it
doesn't even matter if it's an area of
medicine you're going into
uh
the the large drug companies and they
have scholarship programs they have them
but they're again they're they're
they're kind of uh
almost secretive about them and so
uh but you're kind of if you when you're
med school you're going to be like a
nascar driver you're going to be like
wearing patches and stuff
but i didn't know that was the thing
yeah i'm kidding but no you're not going
to wear a patch but the uh but i mean
you know it's you're going to be
sponsored by
you know that's the way it's going to
work in other words and so doesn't mean
you you're obligated to them or
something else the third area and again
these are all and maybe some combination
of these that you find
the large hospital companies are really
struggling
with doctors in rural areas now
and a lot of them are willing to pay for
med school in return for you promising
contractually to work in one of their uh
underserved areas to fund i mean to
staff their hospital for a number of
years you have to do it the rest of your
life but
it's almost
akin to an indentured servant program so
to speak but i mean you get paid as a
doctor but you'd be living in
nothingville somewhere right go at their
hospital because they can't get a dock
out there uh or maybe even an inner city
where they have trouble getting a dock
or something like that but uh uh and
then lastly and this is obvious is the
military
and they'll pay for your med school but
you're gonna serve
as you know as a in the medical corps of
whatever uh branch the military you're
in but they all have
that program and so there are ways to go
through but it's uh it's very very
difficult and i've met people that have
gone through law school debt-free i've
met people that go through um
all kinds of stuff and
so you know you know you ought to pick
up christina ellis's book and read
through it um
confessions of a scholarship winner is
that what it's called is that right
rachel uh yes some president something
like that yeah but christine ellis just
look it up and uh she just came on staff
here as one of our ramsey personalities
she's in the borrowed future video in
the borrowed future documentary and uh
but she got 500 000 worth of
scholarships and went through
did her grad school work at vanderbilt
now she's not an md
but um she's you know
500 000 worth and you can use those
anywhere you want to use them grad
school undergrad whatever and so she
went through freaking vanderbilt which
is unbelievably expensive and paid cash
for every bit of it with scholarships
that she earned and it wasn't academic
and it wasn't athletic
uh and so it's worth you know
being inspired by her story
to keep scratching around this subject
and not just roll over and accept the
normal thing i'm gonna be 250 000 in
debt before i'm an md yeah that's right
and it always is encouraging because we
do get these calls hunter on the show
and meet people out that have gone
through like you said law school
medical school and they've found these
programs they found these avenues and i
think a big part of it too is they look
and they ask the questions and they take
time and they dig into that where i
think a lot of people just it's an
assumption there's no way and
that that's where it stops yeah there's
not as many scholarships for graduate
work of any kind as there is
undergraduate yeah yeah probably ten
percent as many but they're there and
not a lot of people go after them
because they just assume they're not
there
and so you just work on that cipriana is
with us in albany new york hi cipriana
how are you
hi dave hi rachel thanks so much for
taking my call it's crazy to be talking
to you you too what's up
so i have um a revelation that i guess
came upon me this uh this morning a
little background
um i am 27 years old
i have a bachelor's i have a small
business that i run um and i am disabled
i'm legally blind
um
but i am in a really unhealthy
borderline unsafe living situation right
now um it's deteriorated it's the home
with family with my mother and brother
and his girlfriend and you know so it's
a it's a really complicated really
unhealthy living situation that i've
been trying to get out of pretty
desperately for the past six months um
and as you know the rental market is
insane especially in upstate new york
where i am it has the highest jump of
like anywhere in the country
and um because kovid basically and so
i've been looking for six months for a
place to live i've got dogs that are
problematic breeds no one wants to rent
anyone with a kitty or a german shepherd
um and so i've i've been really
struggling um to find a place to live
and i need to get out because it's
really honestly dangerous so i
i'm getting this money um i have a check
in three installments of 14 000 that's
coming to me from back social security
okay i tell you what i want to hear the
rest of the story and give you a good
solid answer but i'm up on a commercial
break so you hang with me through the
break and we'll come back and help you
out kiddo this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at eight eight two
five five
two two five cypriana is who we're
speaking with she's in albany new york
uh legally blind and is in an unsafe
environment with her current living
situation needs to move out having
trouble finding a rental and is getting
some disability payments we got started
on that part of it didn't get the rest
of that story uh as a german shepherd
and i think you said a cat so it's
having trouble finding uh getting a
place to live uh and so on so that's
what you told me so far
um what was how much does the disability
pay out
so it's back payment of about fourteen
thousand dollars total that you're going
to get when will you get that total
um that first payment has already come
through and i think it's gonna be over
the next couple months that made it
sound so i'll get the next one next
month and the next one after that okay
so you're getting four or five thousand
dollars a pop and in three checks
okay right are you working
yes so i've got my own pet care business
that i run and then i'm doing some
freelance uh admin assistant work for a
local company on the side okay what do
you make what's your income
so it varies because i do pet sitting so
it's you know about month by month it's
a little weird but on average um income
is between 25 and 35 hundred dollars a
month
okay and where do you do pet sitting
at your parents house
so i house it so i go to other you go to
their house in people's houses your
house ships yeah okay
some of that sometimes i board i've got
some people that will come to my you
know where i live and leave their dogs
uh from a practical tactical standpoint
i'm not trying to be invasive or uh
unkind i'm just trying to understand are
you you have some sight but you are
legally blind you're able to get around
it's you're you're not completely black
right
right so i have i have enough sight to
do what i need to do but i can't drive
and that's a big a big
issue with that get to those houses when
you're house sitting
it's been it's been family my my father
was also laid off for the entirety of
the pandemic um so he was helping me
just get me from place to place you know
because he didn't have anywhere he could
be so he's been helping me okay and your
german shepherd is a pet or a seeing eye
dog uh the german shepherd is a pet and
i also have a pit bull mix so neither of
which are great for renting
and those and the cats i do have a cat
as well but they aren't the issue
okay
all right um
how old are you
27.
okay and so you're thinking of using
this money coming in to get out of this
situation and you said unsafe starting
to sound like you mean physically unsafe
it it is my uh someone i live with is uh
an alcoholic and
i do not get along and there's been
altercations so violence it's not safe
violence yeah
okay sometimes when people say not safe
they mean emotionally but you mean
physically
well that either definitely it's it's
emotionally unstable i'm i'm needing
clarity here i'm going to understand
what i'm dealing with
yes okay yes okay so that's that's where
that's where i'm at i've been looking
for six months for a place to live to
move out with my how old are you he
would give me
27. okay you told us that i'm sorry i
remember it now okay okay um
you you have an unbelievable
list of
obstacles and difficulties
right
and
sometimes when i get in situations like
that
i stack them at the same level of
importance and they're not
in your story i hear you getting out of
there is top of all the lists
right
if you were my little if you were my
daughter rachel's little sister
rachel would have already gone over
there and kicked the guy's butt and um
then we'd have another problem but um
but the uh but we would have gotten you
out of there right rachel
well that's what i was going to say
sabrina is that i feel i feel like for
your safety as as you're talking and
explain the situation
it almost becomes like that that is
that's the number one thing uh yeah
and i don't want to be the one to say
get rid of your dogs
get rid of the situa you know
i love dogs i mean they're my favorite
thing on the planet
cats not not so much but dogs i'd do
anything to keep a dog but you can't
afford them because they're keeping you
from getting out and being safe
unless unless you can find a landlord
that will allow you to have one or both
of these animals but the chances are
fairly low the pit bull's bad the cat's
bad
you might get the german shepherd in
somewhere if you can you find a
a
landlord that's sympathetic towards you
and i wonder if brianna with all the all
the stuff you've been doing with animals
over the course of a few years i guess
if there's anyone that would take
take the dogs for a period of time even
six to eight months a year
just so you know that you can you can
get them back eventually i've got to
trade your safety for you owning a dog i
know that's that's these are not on the
same level on my list
right and and that i hear you and i i
understand and you're you're not you're
not wrong but the two the two of them
are hard to place long story short one
of the diabetic a lot of medical stuff i
can i can afford her medical stuff
obviously and the other one i'm not
going to allow you to be in danger for
the life of a dog
right period so my question i've been
i've been trying to figure this out is
is it crazy that i've been thinking of
buying saving up enough and using this
money is it crazy because you're not
buying a house for you you're buying a
house for two dogs
well it's partially for me too i see
what you're saying no right now you need
to if you were smart you'd be a renter
you'd get your business stabilized you'd
get something uh close to the houses
that you
uh house it for and you'd use uber to
bring you to those houses when you're
going over there to house sit but uh but
you know you got your two dogs back at
home then and and so um
i i don't like any of this i'm sorry for
you i mean it's a horrible squeeze that
you're in by this untenable thing that
your father is allowing under his roof
so that's a whole nother bag of tricks
to open up but that's his problem so
it's not my dad it's my mom is the is
the problem her dad is on site and he's
allowing someone to
threaten physically his daughter that
would happen about half a second our
place and then bozo be back
my step dad my stepdad is in the in the
in the area he lives in the same
building he's not my actual daddy okay
well bozo would be bounced i'm just
telling you
but you know instead instead of my
instead of my sight-impaired daughter
being put having been run off by for
fear of her life
this is nuts right hey so but you got to
get out of there kiddo
and so you know number one goal is leave
yeah number two goal is find something
that allows you to run your business and
keep your income up so that you can stay
gone and i'd like for you to bank this
14 000 and not touch it you're going to
need the emergency cushion
and then number three goal is try to
figure out a way that some of your
animals make the move with you if any
but they're
as much as i love puppies they're way
down the list here
i'm more worried about you than i am
your german shepherd
sure
i mean you call me up scared of the guy
you live with
you gotta hear yourself
right no enough the only reason the
german shepherd is involved is because
i'm looking for a place with my
stepfather because he helps me get from
point a to point b he's he's his dog so
i could leave with just the pit bull
but i still can't find a place with her
so it doesn't seem oh maybe he'll keep
him
maybe he'll keep the pitbull since he's
keeping the german shepherd maybe he can
keep the pitbull and you get your own
place yeah
i i wish that was a possibility but it's
a they don't get along yet they're
separated it's a work in progress okay
it's so complicated no it's it's not
complicated you're making it complicated
because you're prioritizing your safety
the safety of a freaking pit bull that
won't get along with another dog over
yourself
it's a dog
okay don't get yourself killed over
trying to take care of a puppy
this is silly you're going to have to
break your cycle here you've got these
things two equal in your head they're
not equal and that's not to say we don't
love puppies but we love cipriana a
whole lot more than we love puppies
and we're afraid for your safety right
now because you told us to be
and so we'll be praying for you but
don't you know
yeah
yeah
you can you'll find a place but you're
gonna have to put not put so many
limitations on the place
sorry kiddo sorry you're facing all this
it's horrible
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage michael and kimberly are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you doing doing wonderful welcome so
good to have you guys where do you live
shelby north carolina yeah just outside
charlotte that's a beautiful area yeah
very very cool well welcome it's so good
to have you all the way over here and
doing your debt free scream how much
have you paid off
two hundred and thirty thousand dollars
wow
how long did that take uh four years and
10 months and it was our mortgage oh
look at the weird people
very cool
no debt anywhere of any kind no sir you
are so weird yeah i love you guys you're
awesome how much uh what was your range
of income during that four years and 10
months
so 80 000 up to 130. good yeah wonderful
what do you guys do for a living so i am
a senior director for sales and
marketing for brookdale and i'm a
project manager i just recently started
a new job for a
contract cleaning company out of
charlotte awesome very cool good to have
you guys so what's this house worth
well at the current market i think it's
a range about 250 now i like that well
we count the current market
absolutely we'll take every penny we can
get right every video that's so fun yes
so well done you guys i'm so proud of
you that is just awesomeness this is
neat so uh what happened four years and
10 months ago that makes you go ah we're
going to be weird we're going to pay off
our house because you probably never
thought of it before oh no
absolutely we did not um well it
actually started about six years ago so
we have started a new church anthony
grove baptist church in correct little
town called kraus north carolina and
there was a discipleship class so we
decided to get really
into the program the discipleship class
and our sunday school teacher was
teaching fpu and so we decided to join
we were the joiners and we saw what
success they were having and so we just
we jumped on board as a couple oh yeah
it was
boss
hands down already after that all the
way in
so you just kind of oh let's check this
out and then you got sucked into the
vortex we did we definitely drank the
kool-aid oh yeah
it was a good kool-aid though yeah it
was very good we very much enjoyed it so
about six months in we had finished baby
step number two and we went we were just
kept on going and we said we set a goal
for ourselves um we had 20 and we paid
down on our house and then we saw even
though we knew
our mortgage kind of the statements at
the end when you're signing all those
papers and thought oh no we're gonna
we're gonna pay this off earlier so we
set ourselves a goal for five years we
purchased our house in um january 5th
2017
and um four years and 10 months you've
been about two months yeah wow that's
amazing we beat it by ten months
absolutely and so it's just we we put
everything towards it honestly we just
we kept going we cash flowed school and
we both went back to school during that
time and um it was just amazing i mean
definitely
a god thing every time we thought we
weren't going to make it or something
came up you know we had our emergency
fund we had everything right there um
you know the envelopes were very
religious every he got paid every week
and so we were very religious about
putting the um the money in the
envelopes and every time god showed up
any time that we needed anything
um so it was just absolutely amazing and
we're very blessed we um this is our
fourth getting ready to be our fourth
fpu we're coordinators oh thank you yeah
oh no it's amazing and once a year while
you're paying off your house you
coordinate a class
keeps you on the straight and narrow it
does absolutely and we had an amazing
this class the last time so shout out to
mary grace christian justin they were
seniors um and freshman's in college and
so it was just amazing wow
yeah it was it's just such an
inspiration just to see them and we have
a new couple that um saw that we paid
off our house and just decided hey um we
want to see what this is all about and
so um shout out to jessica and jeffrey
um we're meeting with them and kind of
mentoring them and it's just it's so
amazing god is so good
you guys are so good i love it wow
i love it absolutely so how did it feel
when you sent in and it was just like
okay the last mortgage payment oh we
went and did it in person oh we had to
yes oh yeah we went to talk about that
did they think y'all were crazy were
they like wait what yeah
the guy was like i can't remember the
last time i had to do one of these
so it was kind of a shock to him but
yeah he's like i don't know how to do
this i don't know how to do this i don't
think i've done this enough ever i have
to get out the manual he does he did he
had to get out the manual because i love
it that's so perfect
um did your parents did you guys grow up
like this or are they you the first
bunch to ever get out of debt
first bunch on my side okay um not my
side i would definitely say my dad has
been very yeah so there's four girls
and so he was a penny pincher and so i
learned very young um to save so he's
been cheering you on hard absolutely so
my yes my dad my family's definitely
been cheering us on um not necessarily
our kids they're
yeah our daughter's not necessarily on
board but my son was real on board how
old are they so she is 18 and my son is
14 and she will do the envelope system
very regularly if she wants something
and then she succeeds at it and then she
backs up just a little bit so cheyenne
yes that's she said i don't know if i
love dave ramsey
sounds like an another 18 year old idea
back in the day that's okay as much hate
as i have out there i'll take i don't
love it i'll just take that that's good
i'll take some middle ground i'm good
with that there you go
oh you guys that's awesome did you feel
like you sacrificed cause we talked
about the gazelle intensity and you guys
paid off all your consumer debt in six
months which is incredible
and you pay off your mortgage in four
years so i mean like you guys were still
pretty intense would you say oh
absolutely i don't think we we never
stopped we just saw the goal ahead of us
and his own intensity continued through
oh absolutely for you guys yeah we never
stopped we were hitting every baby step
saving up for um cheyenne's college
engages as well along the way and so we
just never stopped we had a goal in mind
and we met
when you guys are coaching all these
people mentoring all these people what
do you tell them the core thing what's
the key thing things you need to do if
you want to get out of debt uh
discipline uh and if you're a married
couple work together do the budget
together
get on board i wasn't on board at first
with the budget it took me maybe a
couple months
but once i yeah after we did a couple
months of it and i've seen the
difference it could make i was you know
on board i would definitely say just
having an accountability partner being
there and i'm showing each other a
little bit of grace because you don't
you you mess up sometimes i mean i can
say our first budget meeting that we sat
down together i mean i didn't realize
that my kids needed lunch money
apparently so that was one of the areas
that um we needed to work on yeah
you do
there's so much so perfect so much
everybody the first month of budget you
go oh wait a minute you need to eat yeah
i'm probably gonna do it i mean it
happens but yeah so i think just um
having that accountability partner and
setting goals together i think just
constantly sitting down and doing that
budget and um holding each other
accountable um
and delay delayed gratification honestly
how much you guys got in retirement
so we have probably now um
five hundred thousand okay so you're
you're at 750 you're almost baby steps
millionaires yes
i'm so proud of you guys very excited
thank you so well done i love it we've
got a copy of the new book in your honor
it's uh it comes out an early release
we're going to give you an early release
copy uh the actual book comes out
january the 11th it's on pre-sale now
but because you're here on the stage and
you're almost there that's the next
chapter for you guys we're gonna give
you a copy of that and then we'll also
give you a copy of total money makeover
to give away because you're obviously uh
spreading the joy as you said spreading
the love this is awesome i'm so proud of
you guys you're here thank you thank you
great oh yeah it's amazing honestly the
the we were just talking the 30th this
month was our first paycheck um without
a mortgage and so it's just it's the
most amazing thing about this
that's exactly how i feel
it's like what do we do now
so good
all right i love it you guys are amazing
michael and kimberly shelby north
carolina 230 000 paid off four years and
10 months house and everything looking
at weird people they did it making 80 to
130. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream all right three two one
[Applause]
this is how it's done boys and girls you
gotta love it you gotta love it very
well done
man that's amazing
completely changed their lives oh and in
four years like the average is usually
around seven to pay off the house yep
and they just did it they didn't stop i
mean it's the average baby stuffed
millionaire is 17 years they're going to
be there in 10. yeah they're going to be
there half the time on that too so wow
it's amazing pretty stinking cool
so so great slam dunk baby hey what are
you waiting on yeah i'm talking to you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay that couple paid off their home in
four years and ten months
they're mentoring
young people
they're leading financial peace
university classes
they're on their way to being baby steps
millionaires
if you're tired of living paycheck to
paycheck you don't have to be that
anymore
and you don't have to you shouldn't have
to you work too hard to be broke
so no matter how bad you've been in the
past we've all got stuff in the past we
wish we hadn't done
i got stuff 20 minutes ago i wish i
hadn't done but that's the way life is
move on
you need the right plan and you need
somebody to show you how to do it and
that's why so many millions and millions
and millions of people have been through
financial peace university we're going
to show you the plan the baby steps in
detail exactly what to do it's the class
that teaches you not only how to get out
of debt not only how to spend wisely not
only how to invest but to become wealthy
and to become most importantly
outrageously generous
in fact the average family pays off 5
300 in debt and saves 2 700 in the first
90 days of the class
we'll give you the plan but it's up to
you to get started
and uh you can decide today that you're
done feeling out stressed feeling
stressed you're done worrying this this
should be the last christmas that you
worry about money
you need to stop it
i can show you how we've done it rachel
can show you how she's done it uh you
know it's
the the people i mean
the financial peace university class
it's dialed in i mean we've not it's not
our first trip on the cabbage truck
we've done this before
and it's only available in a ramsey plus
membership and you can gift it to
someone or you can get started today
just go to ramseysolutions.com
fpu for financial peace university
that's ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five steve is with us
in green bay wisconsin hi steve welcome
to the ramsey show
hello sir
hey what's up
um
got a question um curious
um we have like 82 000 left on our house
to pay good and that's all we have for
that's all we have for debt wonderful um
i make both 50
50 grand a year
before tax
um
i'm putting away 21
into my retirement i know you only
recommend 15. correct um should i be
lowering that down
to 15 or less to get my house paid off
quicker
um i never heard anything talked about
this i'm just kind of curious what
what's the best route to go
yeah i wouldn't go less than 15 steve
but i would
um
yes i would put it down to that 15
because any of that extra
is where you can throw at your house or
do you guys have kids
everybody's gone
i mean getting to be 60 just about so
and i think we got in our retirement
probably almost 800. way to go
that's awesome that's awesome yeah i
would definitely ratchet down to that 15
and then that means that extra six
percent can be just thrown at the house
and hopefully get that 82. yeah here's
the thing okay let's just talk about
this for a second because sometimes
people get all caught up in the details
but um basically um
you know you only owe 80 000 on your
house if you stop doing retirement as
you're doing it right now all together
it's not about eight or nine thousand
dollars
that does not pay off 80 000 very quick
okay so you've got to have some other
things you're doing to lean in on the
house not just cutting retirement so
yeah i would cut it down to fifteen
percent but that's only three thousand
dollars
less
and three thousand dollars towards 80 is
not going to move the needle much so
does your wife work outside the home
yeah but it's kind of part-time um maybe
ten thousand a year or something like
that not a real lot yeah i so yeah i
would keep doing 15 and i would roll up
my sleeves and just say all right we're
going to be doing a written budget every
month and money we can find we're gonna
throw at this house and if you throw ten
thousand dollars at it it's gonna take
eight years if you throw fifteen
thousand at it it's going to take five
years and if you do twenty thousand it's
gonna take four years and so that you
know twenty 000 is almost 24 000 you
know you're gonna be done in three years
and that's two thousand dollars a month
you don't have that you don't have that
kind of room with your current income so
um
uh you know but we do know that when you
do get to retirement if you haven't got
the house paid off yet then you'll reach
over and pay it off out of your
retirement because you got 800 000 in
your retirement well done so you're a
millionaire man way to go
congratulations
um and making 50 grand look at you i'm
proud of you
ian is with us in charlotte north
carolina hi ian welcome to the ramsay
show
hello hello it's a pleasure to speak to
you you too what's up
um so
i got um i shouldn't say it's a dilemma
but um basically i'm 19 years old i'm
working full-time job as an electrical
apprentice going to school during the
night and online
as in
like for my electrical systems degree i
get my associates in that and
basically i have um
cash flowing my way through that so
that's not a problem um i have a
sixteen thousand dollar um like car
payment that means my mom was splitting
um kind of 50 50 work uh tackling that
pretty good uh
whose car is it
i mean it's under um
where it's technically my mom's but um
we're co-signed under it are you driving
it or is she driving it
no i'm i'm mainly driving it like i
drive pretty much every day to work okay
and how much do you make
um right now i make
um
hourly is um
14 i'm not exactly sure what that is
you're working 40 hours a week
yeah 40 hours a week and then taking
night classes
okay
you have an awfully expensive car
yeah um yeah that's a that's a whole
dilemma but um my
my main question was um how do i
um like i'm kind of a kind of a spender
not online i have a problem of
like if i if i see something you know
i'll
like i'll try to win it out my head and
uh
you know and then it's just sometimes
like it would get the best of me and
i'll buy it and
you know i wake up the next morning like
when i buy that
um and
you know it's not like i don't have the
money i mean i want to put all this to
the debt and it's just
you know it's kind of like kind of like
an addiction almost right you know i'll
see something and i and i buy it and
then you know you don't even know what
happened the next morning until you see
it on your on your bank account it's
like oh man yeah
no
accountability
yeah for sure i mean i would say is
there anyone that you're
that you have in your life that you feel
comfortable that when those moments
happen you can just call
um
i mean not no one like that
my family's been pretty much this whole
um
like that's okay you know they've had
credit cards i mean my parents my mom
still has student loans from i mean you
know she's in her mid-40s and she still
has student loans yeah um okay let me
ask you this when you say it's almost
like an addiction like is that is that
for real or is it or it's just um you
kind of get that adrenaline rush the
dopamine hit all of it because i mean i
can like i'm i'm a spender too dave dave
is a spender naturally well as well so
spending money
uh and enjoying that i think people
people have those feelings for sure
where it's like oh that just felt good
but do you really you think it's you
think it's a step further and more it's
more serious than just
you're kind of having fun being a little
sloppy with the budget
yeah i i'd say sloppy with
are you in a good church
uh no
no i don't really really do any church
like that okay because sometimes you can
find somebody in a setting like that
like a good uh mentor yeah would step in
and walk along beside you
uh
to do that stuff and that's what you
need is that here's the thing
we know you have
self-discipline
we know you have self-control because
you did not rob a bank this morning
because if you had if you if you
couldn't control your actions you would
just go do completely crazy things right
i mean you you didn't drive your you
didn't drive your car through
the last guy that flipped you off you
know we know so we know you can control
yourself you're just choosing not to we
all have that
and uh you know so we all have
impulses that we work against and the
more we work against them the thing so i
i think what you need to do is maybe do
a lot of stuff in writing like write out
your goals of exactly when this debt is
going to be paid off if you stick to
your plan and then you need to have your
detailed budget in every dollar and and
then you've got to have a reason that
goes oh man if i don't do that you know
it's like if i eat that food i'm going
to gain four pounds i can't eat that
food
and so i have to know that about myself
otherwise i eat every doughnut in a 50
mile radius
and so
i have to be able to set this stuff up
and that's that's what's going on and uh
um
i think you need to have a big goal and
you need to have the stuff in writing
and detailed out in every dollar and
that'll give you some help
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsey show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author many times over my daughter as
well is my co-host today open phones as
we talk to you about your life and your
money triple eight eight two five five
two two five alex in kent washington
starts off this hour hi alex
hi dave hi rachel how are you guys doing
great what's up
um i am trying to decide if i want to
take on another
renter i have two currently
i would be converting my current work at
home office into a new room and then
moving my office into my bedroom i'm
trying to figure out if it's worth it
i'm on baby step 2 i have around eight
thousand in credit card debt
and how much would it pay
um it would be around eight thousand a
year
and it'll probably be more than that
actually
okay
so six seven hundred bucks a month
correct and what do you make a year
i make around fifty seven thousand and
the other two renters is around fifteen
hundred
fifteen thousand my qualities
could you just
pay off the 8 000 in a few months alex
and not have to deal with another
roommate
um that is the current plan but i'm also
wanting to kind of pay off my house
sooner than later as well
oh you're having maybe maybe it's a
decision yeah okay so i'm thinking long
run yeah and how much how much do you
have left on the mortgage
um 30 40 340 000 apologies for
how long have you how long have you had
roommates
i've had roommates for around two years
um when i bought the house you've been
pretty successful with that
getting people in there that aren't
torps
uh i've known them from most of my life
so we'll see about the third one if i
get one
okay
good track record so far though yeah i'm
just trying i mean you know you don't
want to mess this up and but uh because
what it amounts to is you got you got
uh
two problems uh relationally one you're
gonna be in closer quarters now it's
gonna be a little more crowded around
there than it used to be
and then two there's four
opportunities for somebody to be pissed
versus
three opportunities for somebody pissed
so and roommate dynamic is a thing dude
i mean even if you've known them your
whole life it's a thing yeah and uh so
you just have to be wise about that if
you can handle the emotional relational
part of it and you want to make that
trade
of some
uh things being a little tighter around
there uh then for some money that's a
reasonable trade there's not a really a
wrong answer here uh you certainly don't
need the money badly enough to take in a
bad roommate right
right
okay
i don't know i'm trying to think for you
alex
in your situation because i'm like
you're
you're making how old are you
i'm 26 26
because i'm like you're you're making a
great income now i mean you're
you know you're over 60
000 70 000 with the uh with the other
roommates rent and stuff i mean you're
doing great
so there's a part of me that i'm like
man why bother well because the gazelle
intensity is the eight thousand dollar
credit card debt but i think you can pay
that off on your own
um and then when it comes to your
mortgage it's it's the thing that we're
like listen you don't have to be as
gazelle tense about some people choose
to be
um
but others don't so i'm always like man
for eight thousand dollars is it worth
it i think what you got to do is
we're putting ourselves in your shoes
and um
i wouldn't do it because i don't like
roommates but uh yeah you're a lot more
comfortable with it you seem to kind of
be not bothered by this just talking to
you yeah so i'm kind of like if you want
to do it there's fine um but uh but but
rachel's point is is there's nothing
there's no whip on your back making you
do this
uh nothing driving you
into this and that that's what you need
to keep in mind benjamin is in boston
massachusetts hi benjamin welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
uh hi rachel how are you as well
yeah thanks for taking my call so i'm 26
years old i make about 72 000 a year
my fiance and i are set up to get
married in june we have our wedding all
planned and we're just kind of getting
stressed out here
it's coming to be pretty expensive um we
both have student loans i have some
consumer debt that might my dad does she
might have
she makes about
50 000 so she's a doctor in residency
right now okay and how expensive is the
wedding
uh we're
upwards of probably about forty thousand
dollars good god
yes sir i agree with you
benjamin's like i know
well i mean for somebody that makes this
kind of money
that's a lot
well so we we live together obviously
we're we're engaged i make about 72 and
she makes about 50 so yeah it's it's a
big budget we are getting help from our
parents but how much help are you
getting from them
um
not they're certainly not covering the
whole wedding but i know how much help
are you getting from them
we don't we're kind of just like getting
help along the way they're kind of you
know okay here's what your problem is
your problem is not the amount your
problem is there's no end to it
because you've not said it you've not
set a wedding budget
no so yeah you guys need to sit down
tonight
and say okay
how much more that we've not paid for
already is do we are we anticipating you
need to set manage this like a project
i don't mind somebody spending a hundred
thousand dollars on a wedding if they've
got the hundred thousand dollars and
they're wealthy people okay that's
alright but don't but don't just keep
spending and then wonder why you spent
too much you need to start the project
and say okay
this is how much we have for the dress
this is how much we have for the uh
reception this is how much we have for
the photographer and this is the total
and we're not going over that and we
both agree to that amount and benjamin
by doing this you guys are going to be
pulling numbers so say you've already
mapped out a photographer and you have
their price maybe you've already mapped
out a caterer and you have their price
like you're now that you guys actually
have things on paper and you're seeing
you may be like oh my gosh because i
know how those situations are and
especially if you don't have a budget
you're in a
you know a meeting with the caterer
trying all this accounts add this and
this because there's no limit there's no
boundary and now that you actually have
facts you guys could go back and make
different decisions on different vendors
and even bring that forty thousand
dollars down some uh is a possibility as
well i'm not saying you guys
will have to do that depending on you
know what the budget ends up being but
having things on paper and seeing the
numbers makes you think differently than
just in the moment kind of going on a
whim
yeah absolutely and my other concern is
that we kind of disagree on how to
handle the money she wants to pay down
her loans
and i think we should be saving and
taking care of the wedding and i'm
trying to convince her to do how are you
going to pay for the wedding if you
don't save and pay for it
i guess that's a fair point but we just
we kind of disagree on what we should do
and i'm trying to convince her to do
financial peace and ramsay plus for
every dollar and i can't get her to
agree that it's worth it so i'm also
looking for advice on how i can convince
her of that
all right we're gonna give that to you
as a wedding present so she has to go
now because it's free and it's my gift
and she's gonna hurt my feelings if she
doesn't
so um because i you know i have a lot of
feelings and they're real i'm real thin
skinned and all and kind of tender and
soft and
benjamin tell her your why tell her your
why
tell her your why of why you want this
smell to say hold on i'll still pick up
we'll get you signed up for fpu dude and
yeah you guys need to pay cash for the
wedding before you pay down your loans
you're right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsey show rachel cruz ramsey
personality is my co-host if you're a
long-time listener you've probably heard
a debt-free scream from someone who
changed their life with financial peace
university
and if you've gone through the class
yourself you're finally discovering some
freedom with your money you're changing
your family tree and beginning to leave
a lasting legacy this christmas don't
just give your loved ones some more
stuff
you can help them find hope
the same kind of hope you found
and just give them financial peace
university it's a great gift
they'll learn the proven plan to save
money get out of debt build wealth
become outrageously generous and now
financial peace university is available
in ramsey plus
members in a ramsey plus membership
get all the tools all the plans
including the every dollar premium all
this is in there to get in practice and
you found hope because you chose to take
control and now you can help someone
else
by helping them with that same level of
hope give financial peace university
today by going to ramseysolutions.com
fpu
ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu our
question of the day is from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure or you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month uh you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from alexander in washington
my fiance and i are getting married late
next year we set a wedding budget of 25
000 and split the expenses based on
percent income percentage
we did this because we have not yet
combined incomes i'm worried that she
will not have her portion of money saved
up in time after three months she has
not made the progress we said was
necessary to stay in line with her
contributions
in the event that she does not meet her
goal should i cover her portion of the
wedding expenses it is not an engagement
ending situation however it is fundament
fundam fundamentally important to me
that she achieved this goal i am willing
to tell her we didn't hit the mark so we
can't have flowers for the wedding
but that seems cheap realistically how
hard knows should i be about the
issue alexander you are a super nerd i
would just breathe alexander breathe
breathe in for four seconds hold
and breathe out
it's okay it's okay
oh alexander
oh
[Music]
alexander it's fine you're fine you're
good listen
you're sweet fiance i mean
i don't yes i do not i pray it's not
engagement ending situation i mean if
she's going behind your back and lying
and a bunch of stuff but if she has not
hit the goals
necessary to the progress
fundamentally i think it's fine i think
you're fine i think you guys enjoy the
wedding i would turn the legalism notch
down like five notches
and she could probably teach you some
stuff alexander yeah poor like xander
i'm starving hard on you
the problem is the problem is what you
and i are seeing is we're seeing this is
going to repeat itself yes and for the
next 50 years
and uh the poor girl is never going to
make her goal
in the 50 years and so
what you've got to do is you have to
back up and go okay this
goal and her not being there and
there's kind of there's a
alexander your voice sounds more like a
father than a fiance
yes it sounds very paternal
with your language
um like you are looking down your nose
at her a little bit like you have all
this figured out and the poor little
thing can't meet her goal yeah um
there's a little bit of uh
that aristocracy crap in here so um you
need to get your nose down your upper
lips gonna get sunburned but um the um
so uh yeah i so i think you need to
address that part of your all's
relationship and this meeting the goal
for the wedding budget is a symptom
of what's going on and so she's not
behaving like you think she should
behave and you are
uh
paternal in your approach
and so i i would say yeah you guys need
to sit down and go okay we gotta learn
to work as a team here and we're both
setting this goal we both have to carry
our weight and so what's this look like
did we did i miss something how are we
going to work together how are we going
to pull this together
but instead of you
determining in advance when she fails
how you're going to grant her grace
instead of being cheap and dirty and
cutting out the flowers
right right
yeah it just sounded yeah no it does it
sounds it just sounds legalistic to me
so i think i think there's a lot of guys
and yeah and and i would want to know
the why obviously if she's sitting there
racking up a bunch of credit card debt
and spending money she doesn't have in
her life and all of that yeah that's an
issue because you guys aren't on the
same page on how money works but if she
just hasn't hit a certain goal maybe
because of her income or yeah maybe she
she just wasn't as strict on the budget
as she should have been i mean all of it
right like there's just
you know the reason that this
conversation is there is more important
than the actual yes issue yes yes
you guys need to work on that in your
pre-marriage counseling because um you
using this voice on her sir long term
it's not gonna work
i can just tell ya
that's how it is oh
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five carla is in
cincinnati hi carla welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave hi rachel thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um my husband and i sold our previous
home and we have proceeds of 300
hundred thousand dollars and
we're trying to decide if we just keep
that put to the side or
if we
keep it with unknown medical expenses
coming up in our future
what are those
my husband was diagnosed 18 months ago
with a rare progressive incurable
disease
and
his two medicines combined
are eight hundred thousand dollars a
year which currently commercial
insurance pays all but five thousand
but he's 63 and um plans to retire in a
couple of years and we're not
sure
what that's going to look like for us i
mean obviously out of pocket it's not
even a doable situation
but he is going to most likely have
other
medical kinds of things as his disease
progresses these medicines just
help us kick the can down the road a
little no carl i'm so sorry wow thank
you
yeah we sold our previous home so that
we would have this nest egg
when we got the
uh diagnosis we kind of panicked and
sold our previous home um
and so that's kind of where we're at so
what are you living in now
well we have a lovely home um we owe
like i said
340 on it do you have any other money
value is
uh yes we have another hundred thousand
in cash that we use for our household
budget
we have two million um
you know in our um
um investments
um our cars are paid for we have no
other debt uh and hold is your husband
63.
okay pay off your house today
you have two million dollars
okay there's two million dollars
i mean i thought you had only had three
hundred thousand of your name the way
you were framing this question
uh it's almost let me tell you those
investments are not sacred they're
they're accessible without any penalty
you're over 59 and a half you may have
some taxes on them or may not but that
you know
if you use this two million dollars on
his health that's what it was for
and you have a paid for house while
you're fighting this rare disease
which lowers the stress level in the
whole process
that's true
that's super helpful because we have a
financial advisor but i don't feel he's
been
super helpful to us and
trying to figure this out yeah cause i
think he's really concerned about you
leaving the two million with him
and not concerned about the emotions
that you guys are going through fighting
this two million dollars
are fighting this rare disease you got
two million dollars there it's there for
one thing to make sure you're okay if
your husband passes and to make sure
he's okay and we if we need to go to
uh
some other country and get some
alternative treatment uh you charter a
jet and you go you have the money
you did it this is why one of the
reasons we have money is to take care of
ourselves yeah i pay off your house
tomorrow and if all this unwinds you can
sell that house
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage bryson and caitlin are
with us hey guys how are you hey
exceptional sir thank you welcome it's
so good to have you guys where do you
all live
um birmingham alabama all right welcome
to nashville
good to have you guys up here how much
debt have you paid off
51
111 dollars sir yeah yeah
and you're uh how long did this take you
11 months eleven months very good and
your range of income during that time
80 yeah 62 to 80. okay cool what do
y'all do for a living
well i'm a active duty inventory army
officer and that's currently teaching
rotc in uh uab down in birmingham yeah
and i've kind of got a lot of different
things so i am a dietitian and i'm also
a grad student and then i'm in the army
reserves as an officer as well is that
where you all met
um no
we have a really crazy story yeah okay i
would say high school sweetheart she
would say i just pursued her quite a bit
in high school yeah but we were in
germany at the time yeah long after she
you were out of high school but she
wasn't is that it yeah yeah when i went
to college
i don't want to know anymore
thank you both for your service yeah
thank you absolutely i mean you guys if
you guys did 51 000 you made fifty one
thousand dollars but you paid off six
i'm sorry i'm sorry you paid off fifty
one thousand but you made sixty two to
eight i mean you guys were i'm wrong you
must sold something yeah it was uh more
i thought i knew what i was doing with
finances having um some brokerage
accounts here and there and when we
finally did this i read one sense in
that book it was like liquidate
everything
so how much did you have that you threw
at it i think that was about 11
that came out of my liquidable assets
i had no idea how to really manage them
but when i just read that wisdom i was
like all right here we go
yeah and so then you paid off the other
30 or 40 by just rolling up your sleeves
and doing beans and rice
yeah yeah giving up giving up meat was
definitely one thing for us
vegetarian i mean i went down to the
plasma center started doing this saving
my tdy trips
yes yes oh my god yeah y'all killed it
that's amazing amazing congratulations
so what inspired all of this a year ago
oh man yeah okay this is my turn yeah
this is going to be it's kind of history
so when everything crashed um and we
were moving to birmingham from uh jbl in
washington obviously post we have gyms
right we have lots of gym state of the
art equipment i come down to birmingham
there's no gems open so i start freaking
out we got to get a garage gem what are
we going to do
well we bought
a garage gem and forked out all the cash
for it and i was like hey we just we we
had a pcs permit changed the station i
put it all on a credit card i was like
the army will pace back don't worry
about it it'll be good which they did so
i can't knock him for that but i just
put everything on the gym for the credit
card and then when i came home one day
after spending another eight hundred
dollars on additional
600 pounds after we already had about
600 pounds of weights in the gym
i looked her in the face and i said
hey i don't think we're going to be able
to pay off the credit card this month
and that was the moment where she
started asking some pertinent questions
that we had never discussed at the
dinner table like so what does our
financial situation look like and for
the first time i had to kind of man up
and say i think i failed you on this one
and uh that that was my moment yeah
coming home realizing my spending habits
just got out of control and i was no
longer the man i thought i was oh wow
how long y'all been married
uh this may will be four years all right
so you're three years into marriage at
that point
and you go okay
you have the old crap moment and uh and
you gotta come clean and you're looking
at each other going okay now what do we
do yeah and what'd you do then
well actually um his current mentor is
actually his boss as well and he really
changed our stars because he introduced
us to
you and um financial peace university
and we just kind of jumped on that
bandwagon and he brought it home and
he's the he's the spender in the family
yeah you talk about free spirits right
yeah yeah
i know i know
he's the free spirit and i mean i don't
ask the right question so i wasn't
asking him about finances
um i was almost like nervous about it
and so
i think it really helped us be able to
communicate about finances which has
just changed our entire year and so it's
just made made us really strong and yeah
yeah and our story when a fulbert
colonel is is asking you relatable
man-to-man questions and trying to
mentor you on a very personal level as a
junior captain you know you take that
moment and appreciate it and you learn
so lieutenant colonel coke i can't thank
you enough for coaching me uh into this
lifestyle and teaching me what i need to
know some of the best servant leaders
i've ever met in my life were
at that level in the military um that
they serve they not just their country
but they serve their men and their women
and this guy's serving you he's a good
leader so caitlyn i want to ask you so
when he
says oh my gosh we can't pay off the
credit card like this is this is the
situation you're thinking wait what what
what so you start dating asking you
describe kind of that
feeling then versus
standing on the stage now
yeah so that's a really good question i
you know i was never like angry or
anything like that um i think i was just
sad in myself too for not being like
strong enough to like kind of pry and
ask about those questions but he was
always like so reassuring like don't
worry about it like i don't want you to
worry about like finances and money like
we're good um so it's it's brought me a
lot of strength in the marriage and
given me a lot more independence and i
feel like i can ask him or like we're
way more open about like
asking each other
do we have the money to spend on that
did we budget for it and like having
those kinds of discussions which has
just made a world of a difference and i
love the budget because i am more the
frugal one and i actually feel like it
gives me more freedom to say like hey i
get to spend money on this because we
budgeted for it yes absolutely so i love
the budget that's awesome that's awesome
well i think that that's what's that's
what is so interesting i think about
money and especially in a relationship
like a marriage is it can it can make
you or break you like i mean it's the
thing that can fracture relationships or
it's the thing that brings
even in a hard situation brings you guys
together and you guys being unified i
think is one of the best testimonies of
this whole journey for you guys over 11
months like just knowing that unity
there is so much stronger than it would
have been i think it's awesome
very well done well done rock stars
thank you sir how does it feel to be
free absolutely amazing so good yeah
conquer anything now absolutely together
yes sir yeah well done
very very well done we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the next chapter in your story the book
doesn't come out until january the 11th
it's on pre-sale now but i know a guy so
i'm going to get you a copy yes sir and
because i want you to be there that's
your next step and i keep keep rolling
on through this and
you got the you got the hard part done
really because you learn to work
together and you decide you're going to
control money instead of it control you
that's a big thing you got to get on top
of it and put your foot on its neck and
you did that so very very very well done
good good job very good job and a copy
total money makeover for you to give
away to a friend maybe you'll have the
opportunity to uh to mentor a guy or a
gal that's uh reporting to you yeah and
you get them started there that'll be
perfect good for y'all all right bryson
and caitlin birmingham alabama 51 000
paid off in 11 months making 62 to 80.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
see that's what happens when 600 pounds
of weight is just not enough
[Laughter]
if you've been married for three years
or 30 years
that moment where you actually start
working together might be the beginning
of the best season of your relationship
ever yep it changes everything and i
remember the first time i was teaching
financial peace university back in the
old days with an overhead projector and
a bad suit and i was conducting the
small group discussions afterwards and a
lady says says um you know this this
this just saved my marriage i'm like do
what
what i had no idea i had anything to do
with marriage i was teaching people
about mutual funds and term life
insurance and doing a budget
and she's like well you forced us to
work together you made us get on one
checking account we actually had to
start talking and stuff you know like
and stuff you know i'm like oh lee wow
and you saved them and i kept hearing
that over and over and over and over in
the years following and then i finally
went oh this is what's going on this is
a a forced meeting of the minds a force
melding of the value systems you're
agreeing on your fears you're agreeing
on your
regrets you're agreeing on your goals
you know your goals and your dreams it's
all there yeah it's awesome good stuff
so great way to go heroes proud of y'all
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day colossians 3 17
and whatever you do in word or deed do
it all in the name of the lord jesus
giving thanks to god the father through
him
albert einstein said the value of a man
resides in what he gives and not in what
he is capable of receiving
open phones this hour rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and my daughter is my co-host
today up next is shelley in san antonio
texas hi shelly how are you
i'm doing pretty well waiting for as
long as i've been waiting um i'm getting
teary-eyed so you have to
i have to apologize
no troubles
i lost my husband in february
suddenly i'm sorry i mean he was 61. i'm
60.
um but um
and um i had i gave my son
the job of handling my finances
which was probably really a mistake but
i knew i couldn't do it
and he's done a good job he's gotten the
financial planner he's he's done well
but all of a sudden
i kept telling him he was playing with
stock
and all of a sudden
they found out that there's like
27 000 in stocks
but i don't know how much she put into
it so i know there's going to be taxes
that to do
is going to be
and
i mean i have a house that i only have
38 000 on
how much other money is there other than
this 27 000 in stocks
well we hadn't done very well with city
money um we had he
i think he knew things were happening
because um he bought extra life
insurance
but it was
375 thousand dollars in life insurance
and you've got that money
i had that money in
with the financial planner okay and i'm
pulling
a monkey him out out yeah how long have
you all been married
uh we have been married 40 years
i'm sorry shelly
and they had waited for five so we
[Music]
did you work outside the home
i did for a while and then i stayed home
with the kids what did you do
i was a
preschool teacher or i worked at with
insurance and neither one can i do now
um for disability reasons okay all right
so here's the here's the thing let me
let me give you an assignment can i
would you allow me to do that
sure okay
um
you do not need a babysitter
you are a 60 year old woman and you're
perfectly capable
your heart is broken
and your stomach stays in your throat
several minutes or hours a day
because of grief
and that just means that you loved your
husband and you're a wonderful woman
that's all that means
okay and it does it does make it hard to
think clearly while the tears are this
close to the top all the time but you're
capable and i do not want you to have a
20-year game plan you're only 60.
i do not want you to have a 20-year game
plan of your son and your financial
planner making all your
decisions i do want them to stay in your
corner and advise you
but i want you to get on top of this
over the next year you have one year to
do it that's your assignment
i want you to understand what's going on
with this instead of asking them what
you can do
ask them what you should do
and then you make your own decisions i
want you to have some power again
yeah because i'm like i don't even know
how much i had in the 401k i know it was
still before and that you know what that
causes that causes you to worry about
stuff you may not even need to be
worrying about
right because you don't have knowledge
of what's going on and you don't have
power if you were the only one that said
something's going to happen and until
you said it it didn't happen
after you
i don't mind them being in your corner
and saying mom i think this is wise or
the financial planner going ma'am i
think this is a good idea and here's
what you could do and you look at that
and you go well
okay but you don't say i did this
because my financial planner said to you
do this because i looked at it i
understood it and i am going to make the
decision now it's going to take you a
little while to get that kind of power
right now because you're dealing with a
broken heart
right and plus i i need to add to the
to the story
he stood beside me
as i was an
alcoholic are you still an alcohol as an
alcoholic you're always an alcoholic but
are you sober now
no as i've been as time has gone on
through the holidays i've been drinking
more okay
then you don't need to make decisions in
that setting until if you're not going
to be sober you don't need to make
decisions
so you're wise to share that so now you
have two assignments
you ready for the second one
get sober amen
that's what he would want
that's what he would want he always
wanted
that's what he always wanted
and it's your best life isn't it
it was my best life when i was over yes
ma'am
okay
so that'll give you the power back me
and
um
the church stood beside me
and
i'm going to stand beside you but the
problem with me standing beside you is
i'm also going to kick your butt
[Laughter]
because i love you and you're going to
straighten up girl okay
i am all right
but i i'm just wondering about
you when you invest i don't know how
much you invested i don't either
i think i'm going to sell that stock and
pay it pay off your house is probably
what i'm going to do
but but we got more important things
than the 27 000 and the 38 000. we got
375 000 land over there we got to get
you sober and we got to get you where
you're making the decisions with a a
clear mind and be from a position of
power and knowledge and you don't have
either one right now
okay so but probably when i get you to a
clear mind and in power say march
you're sober till march
and you're starting to meet with this
financial planner and with your son and
you're understanding what's going on and
they're not having to take care of you
because you're drunk
they're taking care of you and walking
with you and loving you as you're coming
into power and you're throwing your
shoulders back and becoming the woman
that you're supposed to be then you're
going to make the decision to pay off
this house by selling the stock and
maybe a little bit of that 375 as well
and that's going to be a good decision
but let's probably not worry about that
today
okay i just want to make sure i have
enough to move on so now i mean my house
payment's only 700
so
i'm you know
okay don't have this two thousand dollar
house yeah i know but i just want you to
have no payments and have the income
coming in
and that's only
on that detachment card
that i have so one more thing okay
i want to put you into financial peace
university
in ramsey plus
so i can teach you rachel and i and the
rest of the team here at ramsey can
teach you how to handle money and give
you this power
in this area of money so that you get a
sense of control here if i give you this
class for free will you promise to go
through it yes i will okay
and i need you to call me back in march
and tell me that you're sober and that
you're getting on top of this stuff okay
i will do that all right we love you
darling you hold on and austin will pick
up and we'll get you signed up for this
stuff
but uh church standing beside you
husband's standing beside you son
standing beside you
um
and dave and rachel now standing beside
you but understand that what comes with
that is accountability we're gonna we
want you to have your best possible life
and that's gonna involve the things
we've been talking about here today and
i know your heart's broken honey i know
your heart's broken
that was good though i think that that's
a that's a good message of just the the
knowledge brings clarity and it brings
confidence
for everyone so shelley
i pray all good things for you amen
that puts us hour the ramsay show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember that's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you